let's get into audience questions for
the week three good ones this week we've
had they've been pretty good they've
really been pretty good lately
first one hey David have you thought
about instead of voting for candidates
when we vote you're given a series of
policy questions and your best match is
then displayed for you you could still
choose to vote for somebody else if you
wanted but you would at least get an
idea of whether you think of voting for
someone who shares your policy okay I
understand I think the the wording may
not be the clearest but it's a really
good question when you go in you don't
have information about the candidates on
the ballot other than sometimes there's
an R or a D or an I next to their name
or it might say depending on the state
Green Party or something like that
the idea being of course that you've
already done your research and you show
up and you're ready to vote for whoever
you've determined is your best fit
candidate now in reality we know that
tons of people are either voting number
one making a party-line vote where they
may not even really know much about the
candidates if anything other than the
fact that they're a Republican or a
Democrat and they vote for people who
are part of their their party that's not
good but also not good is the fact that
tons of people are actually actively
voting for candidates who they've
researched to some degree but actually
represent the opposite of their politics
I have a ton of friends who growing up
would say I'm a centrist Republican and
I would talk to them about their views
on healthcare and I would talk to them
of other views on taxation and abortion
or whatever the issues were and they
really don't agree with Republicans on
anything so I think that if you were to
show up and basically you get a very
brief sort of like political compass
test or I side with quiz which I did on
a live stream not long ago and then it
comes up as hey you're an 88% match for
Elizabeth Warren if you were planning on
voting for Elizabeth Warren's Republican
opponent maybe you change your mind now
why will this never ever happen because
of exactly what I'm telling you rarely
if ever are people more conservative
than they think
I have not met I can't think of any
people who are who believe themselves to
be on the left and then when you talk to
them about their views it turns out that
they're actually right-wingers and they
should be voting for Republicans much
more frequently in this correlates with
what we know about voter turnout more
voter turnout is good for the more
progressive candidate way more
frequently I have conversations with
people who identify as right-wingers or
center-right moderate Republicans and I
identify that they seem to agree with
Barack Obama or Elizabeth Warren or
Bernie Sanders on most issues so I think
that this is a phenomenal idea it would
be really great if we actually voted in
this way which is here are the issues
that are important to me which
candidates align with that rather than I
usually vote Republican let's just see
who the Republican candidates are if
they're not I don't know an accused
serial child sex offender or whatever
I'm gonna go and and vote for them but
you will never see this allowed because
it would be a disaster for the right if
people on the left and right of the
political spectrum started actually
voting for the candidates who had their
best interests in mind
it would decimate the Republican Party
as we know it so great idea not gonna
happen